if you have two choices to make uh such
as uh you know do i tell this person a
or do i tell them b or do i uh you know
do i take job a or job b um or you know
do i make this sacrifice now or do i go
ahead and do what i want whatever it is
if you have two choices and they're
relatively equal
choices like it looks 50 50 to you this
is key for choices where it's lopsided
you know 175. there was 25 obviously go
with a 75 but if it looks equal to you a
or b and you can't decide
take the path
that is
more difficult and more painful in the
short term
because what's actually going on is one
of these paths requires short-term pain
and the other one maybe requires pain
further out in the future
and what your brain is doing through
conflict avoidance is it's trying to
push off the short-term pain
and by definition if the two are even
and one has short-term pain that means
it has long-term gain and by the law of
compound interest the long-term gain is
where you want to go towards anyway so
your brain is over
valuing the side that has the short-term
happiness and it's trying to avoid the
one with short-term pain so you have to
cancel that tendency out and it's a
powerful subconscious tendency by
leaning into the pain
as most of you know most of the gains in
life come from
suffering in the short term so you can
get paid in the long term working out
like for me is not fun i suffer in the
short term i feel that pain but then in
the long term i'm better off because i
have muscles or i'm healthier the same
way if i am uh reading a book and i'm
getting confused if like i can't
understand what's going on that's just
like working out and the muscle getting
sore
or tired or feeling the lactic acid but
it's not just my brain is being
overwhelmed but in the long run i'm
getting smarter because i'm absorbing
new concepts sort of at the limit or
edge of my capability so
um you you generally want to lean into
things that have short short-term
pain but have long-term
gain my trainer jersey gregorik
aka the creator of the happy body
he has a beautiful short saying where he
says
you know hard choices easy life easy
choices hard life
so what he means by that is if you make
the hard choices in the short term like
oh i shouldn't eat bad carbs or
processed foods or i should go ahead and
do the workout which is difficult i
don't feel like doing it then in the
long term i'm going to have an easy life
but if i make the easy choices in the
short time it's short term like i'm
going to stay out drinking
i'm going to go party i'm not going to
do my work right now i'm not going to
meditate whatever it is then in the long
term you're going to have a very
difficult life you will not have built
up that self-discipline do you believe
that people are incentivized in the
short term which makes them close the
eyes because they think they can get
through the funnel all the time right
it's it's like the same it's like the
first order consequences and the second
order consequences more often in life
life tricks you because the first order
consequences are the opposite of the
second order consequences meaning if you
look at it's like food all the food
that's delicious is probably bad for you
and all i mean a lot of them and the
food
so and and it's the exercise okay and it
ain't fun i don't like it the first
order consequences are the opposite of
the second order
a lot of life it's almost like you're
being tricked and life is going to trick
you i believe that you're going to go
the guy who goes after the first order
consequences without regard to the
second order consequences is going to be
i call it checkers and chess okay people
are always just doing the first that's
right and so that is the key that's why
that's that's why you have developed
that instinct that we just talked about
a little bit ago where you can succeed
from failure how do
a lot of people don't get this most
people don't get this because they think
failure i don't want failure but because
you learned and i learned how to make
the most out of failure my instinct is
almost failure equals success
sounds dumb no it doesn't i call it
failure equals success micro microphone
micro failures macro wins right
because you learn whatever you do as
long as it doesn't eliminate you that's
exactly that's it exactly if you don't
get knocked out of the game okay keep
playing okay how many fighters get
knocked down in the first round and win
the fight
a high percentage
it's just it's just so interesting right
i love this [ __ ] so much right i believe
in this i believe in this tremendously
and and where it takes me and it took
you in a certain path where it takes me
is the inner relationships i think a lot
of people can't execute what you and i
believe in deeply because of their
inability to contextualize feedback of
their inner circle but i i found i built
a whole culture based on this and i
built and i found this
it takes about 18 months to get in the
habit it's all a matter of habit i i
understand and if you create a culture i
understand which it becomes part of the
culture it's like a culture in which
people i don't know are eating and doing
healthy beginnings then it becomes
self-reinforcing and it can be done what
i did in the book was to put together
all the protocols because i'm on a book
not just theory like this i wanted to
get to produce personal change in other
words and if you're doing the personal
change thing you got to do certain
things that are protocols that i try
that i learned over those by making the
mistakes over something like you know
whatever it was 40 some odd years can i
just make a comment on before we go on
to the next topic on this risk-taking
issue
because i think there's a very very
important lesson in my story
most people don't realize that when i
started sun
with scott mcnealy we started another
company a month earlier
and when i see audiences like this
i always ask them do you remember what
company i started and failed
and
nobody can tell it was a company called
the data dump
in my point is the following
your failures don't matter if they're
manageable failures
my life wasn't gonna end if the data
damp failed
uh
i'd be a little bit behind on my rent
but
i'd pick up and start again
and
and we started both data dump and sun
about a month apart
same founders
and my point is failure doesn't really
matter
if it's not going to kill you
success on the other hand everybody
remembers 40 years later
and it changes your life life and
frankly the failures also are probably
one of the more important learning
moments in your life
so i just want to emphasize
what seems like a large risk may
actually in the context of 10 20 or 30
years be a very small risk
because nothing about you changes maybe
you're a little bit smarter
that's about it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you